in mathematical cognition insight is an
activity external to the thing it
follows that the true thing is altered
by it the means employed construction
and proof no doubt contain true
propositions but it must nonetheless be
said that the content is false in the
above example the triangle is
dismembered and its parts consigned to
other figures whose origin is allowed by
the construction upon the triangle only
at the end is the triangle we are
actually dealing with reinstated during
the procedure it was lost of you
appearing only in fragments belonging to
other figures here then we see the
negativity of the content coming in as
well this could just as much have been
called the falsity of the content as is
the disappearance of supposedly fixed
conceptions in the movement of the
notion
what are you reading the phenomenology
and you're looking at Hegel's rather
lengthy and sustained critique of what
he calls mathematical cognition or Kenna
though the way not so much of doing
mathematics per se as a discipline but
the way of using mathematics to
understand understand reality as a tool
as a mode of grasping things and making
sense out of them and in many cases is
something that would be like a last
appeal you know you could appeal to the
mathematics of something there's a few
things to keep in mind one that's very
important is that in you know section 43
and 44 he's kind of fencing around he's
not actually getting to what he's going
to lay out on the table for us in
section 45 so you've got to be a little
bit patient with him the other thing
that for me comes to mind as somebody
who actually had an undergraduate degree
not only in philosophy but in
mathematics and who did a lot of work
with with logic and the foundations of
mathematics is that you know when you're
reading his his criticisms there's a
kind of unfamiliarity that that occurs
on your part really I'm not quite sure
what he's referring to here and this
doesn't seem quite right it's important
to remember that he is understanding
mathematics in terms of the mathematics
available to the you know well-educated
person on his own time that advances
have been made within the discipline and
in the self understanding of mathematics
that Hegel didn't have access to but
which he could have ever simulated we're
not going to try to make sense of that
here because that goes a little bit
outside of the scope of the text which
is already long and difficult enough so
let's look at section 43 itself he says
a mathematical cognition insight is an
activity external to the thing it
follows that the true thing is altered
by it and the word that he's using for
thing is akka so you can understand that
is not just thing like a tangible thing
but the matter what it is that we're
trying
to make sense of and what does he mean
by external that seems kind of a strange
thing to say given that when we think
about mathematical modeling for example
or making sense of something through
mathematics we don't think of that in
terms of something external to what it
is that we're studying instead we we
will often think about it this is the
way many people thought of it at the
time and sort of revealing the structure
revealing the the internality of it
now within Hegelian philosophy the
internality is going to be something
dynamic and that's why mathematics is
going to be something external another
thing that's missing in this passage but
you know on the explicit level but is
implicit that we want to make sense of
he's talking about mathematics and its
relationship to the thing and he says
that mathematics uses two means in
particular construction which we would
nowadays call something like application
we there is still the term construction
but what he used meaning by that is a
little bit broader and then proof of a
vice and the deductive process
mathematics itself is using these as a
means but mathematics is itself a means
for the knowing subject to acquire
cognition of the thing and remember
we're always talking about a dynamic
reflexive process where cognition is
also of the subject and its relation to
the thing so it's not just knowledge of
that thing out there but also knowledge
of oneself in one's relation to it so
it's a little bit more complicated than
that
so mathematics being external means that
it's something outside of the knowing
subject it's a discipline it's a set of
technics or techniques or a technology
if you like that can be externalized
and then you know can be put into
textbooks you can actually take
mathematic
mathematics is the discipline par
excellence that we can in fact make
external and say look over there there's
the equations over there there's the
processes over there there's the proofs
here's your calculus textbook here's the
theory of limits let's take a look at it
so it is external in a certain way and
what he has to say about this the
example that he uses of the triangle and
the Pythagorean theorem it's not the
most apt but you can follow it anyways
he says in our above example the
triangles dismembered its parts
consigned other figures what does he
mean by that
well you know a squared plus B squared
equals C squared what you're doing that
is you're no longer considering the
triangle as such you're considering it
by breaking it down you're analyzing it
you're looking at its relations to other
things you can consider a squared by
itself you can consider B squared by
itself you can consider the Equality
relation by itself and he says only at
the end is the triangle that we're
actually dealing with reinstated and
they're usually actually got his finger
on something important this probably
actually gets to why mathematics is so
difficult for many people and
particularly many Americans when we're
dealing with mathematics were engaging
in abstract thinking whether we like it
or not and we can do as many you know
new math or Common Core examples as we
like we're gonna frame it in terms of
practical problems no mathematics is
always by its very nature going to be
abstract that's what's great about
mathematics it involves a way of
thinking that engages our capacities to
to do abstractions to manipulate them so
it's a formal discipline and when we're
working with it what we're doing is
we're actually breaking things down and
then we're putting them back together so
analysis and synthesis and Hegel is
saying look when we're doing that we
actually lose sight of the things I
think that with the Pythagorean theorem
that doesn't really help us so much
maybe if we're trying to think about
measuring a real-life example measuring
the height of something by looking at
its shadow
something along those lines
that that could be helpful but I think
that when we're thinking about the
applications of mathematics to much more
complex issues or the misapplication of
mathematics to things that have to do
with our day-to-day lives our
subjectivity all those sorts of ideas
that in his critique that we're losing
sight of the thing and that it's getting
put back together at the end it actually
has something to it so the last thing
that I want to hit on with this is he
says there's a kind of falsity to this
you can have a proof that actually
contains true propositions but it's
content is false why is its content
false because you have to abstract from
the Living vital concrete subjective
thing in the process you can say true
things about it and still be doing
something that's in a certain sense
false
but what is really defective in this
kind of cognition concerns the cognitive
process itself as well as its material
as regards the former we do not in the
first place see any necessity in the
construction such necessity does not
arise from the notion of the theorem it
is rather imposed and the instruction to
draw precisely these lines when
infinitely many others could be drawn
must be blindly obeyed without our
knowing anything beyond except that we
believe this will be to the purpose in
carrying out the proof in retrospect
this expediency also becomes evident but
it is only an external expediency
because it becomes evident only after
the proof this proof in addition follows
a path that begins somewhere or other
without indicating as yet what relations
such a beginning will have to the result
that will emerge in its progress it
takes up these particular determinations
and relations unless others alone
without its being immediately clear what
the controlling necessity is an external
purpose governs this procedure
section 44 is also very short and really
can be encapsulated I think very quickly
there is something important going on
there he says that what's defective
about about mathematical cognition he
says there's the material we've already
just looked at that in section 43
mathematics in a certain sense falsifies
the very object that it works on in
revealing its its mathematical sides you
might say in part by presenting that as
if that's what's really essential to it
but it's the cognitive process itself
that Hegel is saying is defective in
mathematical cognition one asks his
question well why and he gives us an
explanation
his explanation ends up turning on two
terms or concepts that are that are
quite important one of which is you know
very closely
you know paralleled in the translation
necessity no vendee kite that's a
standard you know term for necessity
understood in the sense in which we
would say it in other languages as well
but then there is another interesting
twist what we're getting here in the
Miller translation is expediency is that
messy kite and vac memes goal or end so
being measured or appropriate to the
goal or the end this is a kind of an
interesting thing to point out there's a
little bit of a digression but when we
talk about rationality earlier on in the
phenomenology he's using that same term
Zek messy reason proportions itself to
certain ends or certain goals and this
notion of and/or goal is going to be
important in what his critique is here
so let's look at what he's saying he
says we don't see any necessity in
mathematical constructions and in a
certain sense it's almost a red herring
here he says look you know if you don't
have to make a mathematical construction
you can make it any way you like you
know you need a line going through this
point well you got a hole
and basically infinity those lines and
sure I mean we know this from that's
just sort of basic geometry is that what
he's after in saying there's no real
necessity what he's saying is that what
we think to be necessity which we
actually take as a hallmark of
mathematics and of course of the most
mathematize the closest to to
mathematics of the scientific
disciplines physics we often think that
what we're working with is necessities
and you know for example when we're
teaching logic this is why I have this
the syllogism up here if a then B a
therefore B we would say well that's
that's a necessity
that's just modus ponens right isn't
necessary though here's what we have to
be ask ourselves why eight why this why
did you actually put these two together
why did you stress that and so you can
frame a larger thing outside of the
situation and say yeah you're right once
you actually have if a then B and you
actually have a then B has to follow
from that that's all fine
that's necessity that's logical
necessity right there that's apodictic
you know if we want to use content or
even Aristotelian terminology in its in
its modality but why do you have to have
this in the first place maybe if they
not always be maybe that's something
that you're assuming so that you can
make the processes that you want to work
work maybe that's something that is
mathematically true but you have to ask
yourself well why did you set things up
in the first place that way and I'll
give you a great example of this you
know I used to go to political science
conventions and I would go to these
these quantities quantitative analysis
sessions which most most of the stuff
that they're doing in political science
tends to be number crunching
dad data analysis and I would go for the
political theory but that's a whole
different conversation so I would go to
these things and it would be on
something that I was interested in like
you know political movements in Europe
and then they would do you know these
analyses and they would say well we've
looked at the EU's 38 political parties
and we've put them on this spectrum and
you know we've got this five five point
thing ranging from most conservative the
most radical or most liberal you know
most most progressive and then you you
know they do some some analysis using
some very sophisticated statistical
techniques and then they would argue
about why did you apply this statistical
technique and I'd look at this and I'd
be like well why the hell did you divide
the data up that way anyway
I mean this doesn't seem like that great
of a fit and every time I'd ask those
sort of questions they would give me
blank stares and saying well you know we
we just used this model that we found
over here and I said well why did you
use that model why was that appropriate
the lack of sort of stepping back and
reflexivity is what Hegel is criticizing
as lack of necessity here in order for
something to really be exemplifying
necessity for a rational subject there
has to be an answer to the higher order
why and he thinks that mathematical
cognition is missing that
the evident character of this defective
cognition of which mathematics is proud
and on which it plumes itself before
philosophy rests solely on the poverty
of its purpose and the defectiveness of
its stuff and is therefore of a kind
that philosophy must spurn its purpose
or notion is magnitude it is just this
relationship that is uh nacelle lacking
the notion accordingly this process of
knowing proceeds on the surface does not
touch the thing itself its essence or
notion and therefore fails to comprehend
its in terms of its notion the material
regarding which mathematics provides
such a gratifying treasury of truths is
space and numerical unit space is the
existence in which the notion inscribes
its differences as in an empty lifeless
element in which they are just as inert
and lifeless the actual is not something
spatial as it is regarded in mathematics
with non actual things like the objects
of mathematics neither concrete sense
intuition nor philosophy has the least
concern in a non actual element like
this there is only a truth of the same
sort that is rigid dead propositions we
can stop at any one of them the next one
starts afresh on its own account without
the first having moved itself on to the
next and without any necessary
connection arising through the nature of
the thing itself further because of this
principle and element and herein
consists the formalism of mathematical
evidence this kind of knowing moves
forward along the line of equality for
what is lifeless since it does not move
of itself does not get as far as the
distinction of essence as far as
essential opposition or inequality and
therefore does not make the transition
of one opposite into its opposite does
not attain to qualitative imminent
motion or self movement for it is only
magnitude the the unassailed esteem a
the Mattocks deals with it abstracts
from the fact that it is the notion
which divides space into its dimensions
and determines the connections
Queen and within them it does not for
example consider their relationship of
line to surface and when it compares the
diameter of a circle with its
circumference when it it runs up against
there in commencer ability that is a
relationship of the notion something
infinite that eludes mathematical
determination
in section 45 we now start to get closer
to the heart of the matter and Hegel's
made a few important criticisms of a
sort of over reliance on mathematical
cognition in doing philosophy and
attempting to make sense out of the
world the knowing subject to all these
sorts of things now he's going to levy
one of his main criticisms and here's a
place where I would actually suggest
that it could be useful to go outside of
the phenomenology proper he has a
similar set of discussions that are
ongoing early on in the science logic is
his first logic not the encyclopedia but
the science of logic which is the work
that follows this one where he's
discussing quantity
yeah and he's going to use somewhat
similar analyses he's gonna frame it in
somewhat different language but it's
really the same sort of criticism only
carried out a little bit more more fully
there so he says that when it comes to
mathematical cognition its purpose and
notion it's vac and McGriff you notice
we just talked about vac and purpose
goal what what it is the reason the
motive why you're actually doing it he
says that the purpose of mathematics is
in fact magnitude grosser in in German
or quantity if we want to express it
that way number now what does that mean
well mathematics wants to turn
everything into number because that's
what it can make sense out that's what
is one of the problems with mathematical
cognition and it's the Gryff its notion
its concept is an impoverished one
because it's going to frame everything
in terms of quantity and what you can do
with monies and now he's not knocking
quantity and as a matter of fact of
Hegel were around today and he was
looking at you know what we can do as
computer modeling he'd be saying or what
we've advances we've made with
statistics he'd say
this is incredible but it's still
subject to the same ultimate critique
Hegel would for example be you know a
great fan of girdles and completeness
there I mean it's a yes of course
so what can we say about this he says
that the evident character of this
defective cognition of with which
mathematics is proud mathematics has a
tendency and those who you know latch on
to mathematics have a tendency to become
a bit arrogant about its capacities to
model its capacities to apply its
capacities to provide us with the basis
for things he says rests solely on the
poverty of its purpose which is just to
work with number mathematics is not able
to take in if let's say we want to think
about this in older terms of the
Aristotelian terms Aristotle classed
quantity as one of the accidents and he
thought it was an important thing
he didn't give as much stress to his
later philosophers like say de Carter
Spinoza would but he thought that it was
important he talks about it in his
metaphysics but he thought that
something else was more fundamental and
here Hegel is fundamentally Aristotelian
quality it's a poem in Greek father's
death in German quality something
determinative that goes beyond mere
mathematics mere number mere quantity
mirror you know statistical modeling
something which escapes that not just in
one dimension but but in multiple
dimensions that was what Aristotle
thought was closer to being of course he
thought that substance was most real and
then quality and then quantity and then
you got all the other stuff as well so
quantity is important for Aristotle
Hagel has a mind set very much like that
except that quality and substance almost
kind of switch roles back
and forth because it's a dynamic system
not as static as Aristotle's admittedly
dynamic system turns out to be so he
says its purpose or notion is magnitude
and this is uh nacelle lacking the
notion so it's its concept is in a
certain sense Hegelian concept less it's
it's better if is be drift offs in
German so he says accordingly this
process of knowing proceeds on the
surface of things does not touch the
thing itself or its essence for its
notion so mathematics and mathematically
based ways of approaching things through
state technology through computers
through algorithms can't really get to
the heart of things they can do a lot
but they they blind us to the fact that
they're not actually getting to what's
essential and he says the the reason is
because its material is space and
numerical unit in the logic he is going
to speak in terms of discreteness and
continuity rather than in terms of space
a numerical unit but it's really you
know working with similar stuff he
they're healable
you know somewhat he'll distinguish
space and and and continuity but here we
can sort of blend them together so
mathematics works with spaciality it
works with you know arranging things in
spatial terms think about you know a
three dimensional grid like Cartesian
coordinates allow us to do that's you
know mathematical space and the
numerical units one two three four five
you know add in all the other things for
actions irrational numbers those are all
mathematical units and some of them may
be defined in terms of relations to
others but they're all turning up being
understood in terms of the units and
some sort of sequence so he says space
is the existence in which the notion
inscribes its differences in an empty
lifeless element that's a problem an
empty lifeless element
rather than what we actually experience
so again remember we're dealing with a
phenomenology here we want to be
attentive to what it is that we actually
experience what it is that we are
actually conscious of are we ever
conscious of empty space no that's an
abstraction within which we place things
a useful one but it is still an
abstraction nothing actually exists in
space everything exists in continuity
with everything else and pushing on
everything else that's the way we
experience reality even what we call
empty space you know we experience as
you know places where we can move around
do things there's still relation ality
there's still an experience that it's
not purely abstract and and empty and so
he says the actual is not something
spatial as it is regarded in mathematics
with non actual things like the objects
of mathematics neither concrete sense
intuition neither the the way in which
we experience the world when we're not
doing philosophy when we're just engaged
in the natural attitude as Woodrow
called it nor philosophy has a least
concern in a non actual element like
this there's only a truth of the same
sort rigid dead propositions and this
gets to the heart of what Hegel wants to
say here
he says mathematics and mathematical
cognition focus on focuses on equality
abstract equality and it's not adequate
to life it's not adequate to lived
experience it's not adequate to the
fullness of what something dynamic would
actually be so any mathematical model is
going to be at best just a model it's
certainly not able to take into account
self movement things that choose at
least in the instance of human subjects
choose what they're going to do that
grow that develop that decline that
engage in conflict some of this can
again be modeled sort of an
some tonic way by mathematics but
mathematic still remains on the
superficial on the surface of the things
so he says what is lifeless since it
does not move of itself does not get as
far as the distinctions of essence
numbers are actually lifeless numbers do
not move themselves numbers are not
going to be an adequate means for
understanding the realities that we're
trying to make sense of he says they
don't make the transition of one
opposite into its opposite that's
something that you know if you're going
to do mathematics you have to sort of
leave behind there there are some
exceptions of course you know theory of
limits has some interesting ideas along
those ways if we're doing calculus and
it you know this is one of those places
where we could say well Hegel what about
this what about this what about this but
let's just follow him on this what he's
saying for the most part does hold
you're not able to take account of
quality in its metaphysical sense
adequately through a metaphysics of
quantity and that's what mathematics in
effect is a metaphysics of quantity so
he says you can't attain to qualitative
imminent motion or self movement for
it's only magnitude the unscented
distinction when he says on a central
distinction he doesn't mean totally
honest enchi yet the real heart of the
thing not getting at what we want to be
studying through going through the
phenomenology of consciousness and its
development through history and time so
he says it abstracts from the fact that
it is the notion which divides space it
is the concept in its full sense in the
living sense embodied in subjects which
actually does divide space which gives
space reality
meaning this is a very very important
point something that we'll come back to
in later parts of the phenomenology so
he says and determines the connections
between and within them it does not for
example consider the relationship of
line to surface and when it compares
he's got some examples here it runs up
against in
commencer ability in commencer ability
is a relationship of the notion now
where we could actually pause here would
be to think what about like you know the
the paradoxes of set theory or what
about some of you know Cantor's
reflections on transfinite numbers okay
again once again we have areas where
maybe Hegel didn't have as much of the
mathematics as we do now and you know
the question that we'd have to ask is
could he actually embrace that and and
bring it within the systemic perspective
that he's looking at here and say well
in that respect mathematics actually is
involving a sort of concept or would he
go further and say look Kant or is a
subject the people doing the paradoxes
of set theory they're you know they're
they're not set theory itself they are
living vital subjects that are engaging
in this through the processes of
liberation allottee and experience and
cognition I think he would go with the
latter so this is an important part of
his criticism of mathematical cognition
but it's not the entire thing and now
we're gonna have to proceed further into
this